we are
all right good morning um
as chair of the house legislative
administration
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covid 19
pandemic in accordance with house rule
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee
and scheduled in the house calendar for
today
an executive session may be held on any
bill referred to the committee please
note that there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar
on the general court website the notice
for this meeting complies with house
rules
and rsa 91 a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call area
code 603
to
or email h c
s at ledge l e g
dot state dot nh dot u s
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by
roll call vote let's start the meeting
by taking roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required by
right to know law with that i'll ask our
here and there is no one in the room
except for me
i am present and moving to a private
location in my home
representative greene i'm here my home
in hudson
and my wife will be in and out
representative hill here
in the legislative administration
sumptuous room representative
lay i am present i am a home in jaffrey
and i am alone
representative mckinney here alone
in londonderry
i'm here um i'm alone in my office
representative osborne
representative packard oh
representative richards i am
here i am currently alone in my office
there may be
a person passing through from my staff
very rarely though
representative roulard i'm here in my
home
in alone in the room however my husband
may be running through every now and
again
and the clerk is here alone in my home
office
representative simon here alone in my
that i see actually the picture of the
committee room looks a little strange
because it looks like i'm hiding behind
the
uh the monitor it doesn't look like
anyone's in the legislative
administration
meeting room for some reason they gave
us
the largest room uh house finance so
so it's uh for one person it feels a
little silly sitting in here but i
have to admit um the time being 905
and in the calendar at nine o'clock we
have hearing
for house bill 186
i will open the hearing on house bill
this is an act repealing certain
inactive committees
and revising the membership or duties of
certain committees
councils and boards with
that that share there are four people
signed up to speak
currently um the chair will call the
prime sponsor
uh representative karen ebel
welcome thank you good morning mr chair
and uh good morning committee members
for the record my name is karen ebel and
i represent merrimack district five
and it's my pleasure to present to you
this morning
hb 186 which is a bill to repeal
inactive
committees and revising the membership
and duties of
of certain other committees and i urge
you to
pass it after you review it and make
your own
comments i want to say that this bill
is the culmination of over two years of
work by two committees on committees
and house committee services researcher
pam smarling
when i was first appointed as deputy
speaker a couple of years ago
i one day offered to help with
appointments to these statutory
commissions
and it started a very long journey
i was very surprised to see that what
was required was almost
300 appointments to about to over 200
statutory committees
it's a staggering task for any incoming
speaker
and after uh some discussion working
with house committee services we decided
to make a comprehensive
list of these committees we looked at
their um
to assemble the frequency of meetings
and their responsibilities and that sort
of thing it took
pam months and months of work to
assemble
a very complete chart of all of these
i introduced a bill to form a committee
on committees
and the governor in the meantime great
minds think alike he introduced
he added into the budget
hb 4 at the time committee on committees
was established
to look at all the existing statutory
committees
and also all committees that were
created by executive order
um because the budget wasn't signed into
law until october 2019
and we had to report by february 1st we
had a very compressed time schedule
but we did an awful lot and most of it
was because pam had done as much work as
she had
my original bill hb 1245
put into place the recommendations of
that original committee of committees
and created a new one so we could finish
our work
that was signed into law we met
for uh several months completed our work
and hb 186 is the
uh by is the result of the bipartisan
report of that committee on committees
um
it too repeals and makes adjustments to
several statutory committees on the
committee
i chaired both of them was
representative mary smith
i mean mary heath dave danielson
sharon carson and cindy rosenwald
our charge we felt was to simply
review um and make no substantive
changes to the responsibilities of the
um
of the committees um and we tried to
tweak
where necessary to make them more
relevant and if they hadn't been meeting
for a really long time
uh you know to to talk about repealing
them
i want to uh i think it's important that
the committee understand
uh the review every
administrative agency came in to discuss
the statutory committees and commissions
that were associated with their agencies
and we discussed their history their
frequency of meeting
purpose and their need for continued
existence
members of the committee our committee
on committees
also conferred with commission and
committee chairs
to get their input and the
recommendations are
the culmination of a great deal of
discussion and review
and we strictly i mean we strictly
adhere to
our charge of being administrative and
not substantive
in our in our review
members of the committee may recall that
in 2010
uh former representative neil kirk and
lori harding pursued a similar course
it had been a decade since the statutory
commissions had been reviewed
and it was time to renew them again
because they do proliferate
rapidly the hb4 committee on committee
report made a number of recommendations
to try to tackle these changes
and to make the work of these committees
more
meaningful that's also attached to the
report of this committee
i just want to say among the most
important recommendations
we made was for hcs to constantly keep
updated the list of committees
and by and to include by rule the
responsibilities of this committee which
you may not like
to do a periodic review of the
outstanding committees
a decade is just too long and it
shouldn't
require almost two years of work to do
this
every 10 years and it just would be a
lot better
if we could keep things updated in my
testimony
i included the recommendations of the
report
i was going to include those in my
testimony today
but i um it's right there
a lot of it has to do with just making
sure that the standing committees
are aware of the statutory committees
that work
on topics that are relevant
to their committee and we want to make
sure that
the staff the standing committees get
the reports
that these statutory committees do
because many times they just go to the
speaker's office and the senate
president and the clerk
and they never get to where they need to
go um
so i'll just i'll wrap it up there
as far as my testimony is concerned and
i'm happy to take questions of the
committee
i just because i heard the comments in
the beginning of the
of the meeting i just wanted to say as
far as the
the youth advisory council the only
change we made
there was to instead of just having
membership be post-secondary students
we expanded that category to high school
and post-secondary because there was a
lot of difficulty
based on the um testimony we took
in getting secondary uh post-secondary
students so that was the only thing that
was done there
and as far as fish and game my
recollection of the testimony and this
is
going back a while was that there was
some
um difficulty in in getting people just
from the seacoast if i remember right
and also
a sense from the testimony that we got
that uh marine resources was more than
just a
seacoast issue um
but other than that um i'm happy to take
your questions
i i again i just want to assure the
committee that this was done in a very
comprehensive way
and i want to um take the opportunity to
thank pam smarling
because if it wasn't for her back up for
this uh we
we never could have um accomplished it
so with that um i'm happy to take your
questions
thank you thank you um and i'll
second the notion that uh pam smarling
is a
star among stars here for all of us um
you said you will take questions i will
look to the committee to raise their
hand or
signal somehow if they have questions
for
representative evil
seeing none i will ask um
one one is would you be willing to stick
around for a minute while
we talk with um with
the other agencies that are asking um
questions of us it may be best if you're
available
are you available for a few minutes sure
i'm happy to stay
um okay i also could you also just run
through again for me
the um the process that you went through
did you
um was it
looking first for low-hanging fruit were
you looking for committees that hadn't
met
for a certain period of time and and um
and that was an indicator or where did
you go from there
well basically what pam did over months
and months of work is she compiled this
huge chart um which is attached to the
report
and she identified the
the committee the statute
she tried to track through where they
were listed on a website
some of them i mean that's among the
recommendations of our committee you
couldn't even
find them then she tried to find the
history of of when they had met
last and if she couldn't find it on the
website she reached out to
administrative agencies
and we could see from the chart that she
put together that there were a lot of
committees
that hadn't met in a really long time
so we went so we tried to be
thoughtful about how we would approach
it
and so what pam did is she basically
figured out every statutory committee's
uh
link up to an administrative agency
and we she reached out to the agency she
told them this is the list of committees
that we've identified that you're
administratively attached to and we
brought the administrative committee
in so while we were driven in part
to try to um get rid of the low-hanging
fruit
we didn't think that was the best way of
approaching it just because we did we
weren't totally sure of
who was meeting when based on the
information we had
and we just started with the
administrative agencies
and they did a phenomenal job of
summarizing the work that they do with
the
with the different agencies so what
you're seeing here
is the second committee on committees
the first one
um i think we reviewed over 200 um
organizations so it wasn't just whether
they meet or not like for instance i
think it was something like
county finance they had met in a really
really long time
but um the agency came in and said no
they're really important when we need
them we need them
so that's the other thing to just leave
some of them in place in case you need
them
i just uh just to keep going like
there the bill isn't just a couple of
pages because whenever you repeal a
committee
you have to go through all the statutes
and see where the committee is
referenced
so you have to delete the the cross
references
and then the other thing that we tried
to do some of these committees they
could have 15 people on them and it just
wasn't
necessary and in an effort to reduce the
legislative burden
in some cases we like if they called for
five house reps we
we made it three things like that
thank you um what we have in front of us
uh this bill came before legit for for
the people that don't
realize this this came before
legislative administration last year
i think it got bogged down in the in the
senate is that right
well what um actually what happened was
so um hb4
created a committee on committees and
then hb
1245 contained the recommendations of
the hb4 committee
and also created a second committee on
committee so we could finish our work
and so hb 1245 was the lead bill
on an omnibus that was put together and
so
uh and so the governor signed into law
that on the bus and since that created a
committee on committees then i chaired
the next one
and so we did some more work finishing
up our work and that's what hb
186 is so so usual
is 186 the
updated version since the last time
legislative administration
saw this or it's a different bill
basically what it does is it embodies
the second part of the
work that we had we had to do i mean
without getting
uh you know i won't talk about the bill
numbers basically we had a committee on
committees we had a report date
uh we couldn't finish all our work in
the first part of it
so we introduced another bill and we
finished up
and we finished up in the in the next
round
so what you see here is a new bill that
i just introduced based on the second
half of the committee on committee's
work
and so it's a whole different set of um
committees being repealed etc
see representative lay with his hand up
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking the question so
clarify for me representative evil i'm
i'm a little lost on this
so we did consider last year
i believe a bill introduced by you
to alleged men which
streamlined you know eliminated certain
committees or abolished them
things like that okay what happened to
that bill
it was signed into law okay so that's so
so
following we're done okay so follow up
mr chair i just want to be sure
absolutely
yeah so so then this bill is simply
a continuation but it is not repetitive
this is all new
we have not seen this before okay thank
you
yeah that i think that was my confusion
as well um
that's um the only
there was one other question i had in
there for you and now i've lost it
um but i'm sure it'll come back
um thank you very much for your
testimony if you'll hang on for a moment
we
we may have other questions for you as
we go
um representative green could you uh
and promote her i am not seeing her at
the moment
but should we move on to the next person
sure sure okay i got a text from her she
said she's hung up in the other meeting
and she won't be able to attend but
i kind of explained what was going on
in this bill as far as lyac is concerned
okay
she was signed up in support so i'm sure
whatever
she had to add you've already given us
is that
yeah as i say uh her only concern on
on lyac was just that they were having a
hard time attracting
post-secondary students and since that
requirement was in there
she just asked if it was added to
um to high school because
she just didn't she thought it would be
unfortunate if a seat was not filled
um because it was required to be filled
by post-secondary
okay i thought of my other i thought of
my other question
um when when you spoke to um
agencies um did you go
into the into the details of of
um specifically in this fish and game
question we have
would you have gone would it be normal
practice for you
to have gone as deeply into where
membership should come from
would that be a normal practice i think
it's i don't recall
the precise conversation with them
i guess i have to go back to the process
that we
um that we did and we tried really hard
not to make
changes that were really dramatically
um altering my recollection again
is that we i wouldn't have made that
change if we hadn't or we wouldn't the
whole committee wouldn't have
recommended that change if we hadn't
discussed it with fish and game
and felt like there was consensus there
again
the only reason that might have been
changed
is because there was some sense that
they were having trouble
filling it in with people i that one i
don't know and again i i just want to
say
it was never the intent of this
committee to make
substantive changes um that
would alter things you know
substantively we had several people i
will say agencies come in
um and say you know this really needs to
be revamped this isn't working
and and we would say to them that's not
our charge
um you need to go back and introduce
um a new bill to accomplish the things
that you
want to accomplish we were kind of a
cleanup crew
i mean that's the way i viewed it so if
it's perceived
by fish and game that we did something
substantive that they disagree with
i you know um i'm i'm not going to stand
here and say that they shouldn't do it i
would just say that our process
was such that that's what we thought the
consensus view was
did did the committee on committees make
any recommendation
as to how often this should be done if
it's not every 10 years
well the thing is that
these things proliferate like crazy
and my thought the committee's thought
was that
the ledge admin committee
at least every five years could create
an ad hoc committee of some sort
and just start to review these things so
this was a
sort of a routine thing that the
committee did
10 years is really really too long and
this was
you can see it was a two-year process
and it's hard for me
to to figure a way that it would be
uh quicker than the time that it took
i had hoped this time around that we
might be able to get a rule
to amend the responsibilities of the
legislative administration
committee to include a review
but um that wasn't approved by the rules
committee and i think in part because i
didn't
i wasn't there to sort of present it
um that it was the recommendation of
this committee and all the reasons why
we thought that was a good thing to do i
mean you guys can do it whether it's in
the rule or not but
it needs to be done more than every 10
years
you know it's sort of like it just
builds up and builds up and builds up
and then somebody goes ah this really
needs to be reviewed and then somebody
introduces a bill
um it shouldn't be that way it should be
a routine procedure and
you know i i know we're talking about
the specific bill but i really hope when
you guys have a little breathing room
you can look at the report
and the recommendations because there's
stuff there like how ols
should interact with the members um you
know
make sure they anyway well
we won't be we won't be executing it
today um
so it is something that the committee
has the ability
to take a look at um any idea
you weren't you went from the 300
appointees that had to be made to
various committees do you know what the
number
dropped to after um i didn't go back and
count
you know i i will say for all the effort
i i kind of wish we were able to cut out
more
but you know people came in and said
some
they were useful i think in the end um i
don't know pam might know better than me
maybe we repealed about 40 but we
reduced the membership of a lot
let's say 50 to 60. okay
yep it's a number um thank you very much
again
um are we set now to bring in
um the insurance department
sorry about that okay here we go uh
mr brennan hi thank you so tyler brandon
with the insurance department
welcome you're you're
you're willing to uh up you're muted
thank you i um i thought i'd lost you
there for a moment
so um this is uh we are in support of
the bill
it's uh not something we requested but
this committee that it repeals the
insurance oversight committee the joint
healthcare
committee is a perfect example i think
of the the kind of committee that was
considered obsolete this committee was
created 10 years ago
really when the aca federal law was
being rolled out
and at this point it's it's completed
its mandate
it really was involved in some of the
state-based decisions we would have to
make
although most of those decisions were
are we actually going to do this at the
state level and not have the federal
government take it over for us
so there were pretty easy decisions um
the technical amendment that uh we did
suggest
support for really just uh is to make
sure that
other references within the same chapter
to the oversight committee
are also taken out but we do see those
changes as purely technical
um because this committee is obsolete it
doesn't mean some of the discussions
that
would be big policy uh decisions at the
state level
uh the kind of decisions that wouldn't
need legislation and of course you know
a lot of important decisions will end up
in legislation is a commission that's
called
the commission on the status of health
coverage markets for individual and
small employers
and this is a great group because it
includes legislators it includes folks
from the carriers
and show insurance brokers employer
representatives and that's where a good
fruitful discussion can take place
of any policy decisions that the state
might move forward with
instead of this this other joint
healthcare
committee that would be now removed
so um not much more to add to that uh so
we support the
the bill in this particular section uh
it is we are i am referring to
lines seven through nine on page one if
you have any questions but it's a
relatively small part of
the overall bill happy to take any
questions
uh thank you for your testimony um are
there
as i understand it you just want to make
sure
as a technical housekeeping item that
all references are removed when when
that committee
or commission is removed yeah so the
bill essentially moves
the main paragraph that uh that the
committee is described but there are a
couple of other parts of the chapter
that refer back to that
so and it's real nice because you can
just take it out of the portion of the
sentence without changing
the rest of the chapter so it's um they
should be easy fixes
okay um seeing no
questions um i will thank you for taking
the time and
coming to speak with us thank you
um representative green can we
we just pulled up uh paul sanderson mr
sanderson
welcome to legislative administration
i think you're muted on your end
there you go thank you thank you very
much mr chairman uh
i've been listening to your proceedings
so far and i'd like to heartily agree
with representative ebel about the
process that they followed
uh it was in fact cooperative and
collaborative
um and you'll note that we have actually
two agencies
two of our uh boards in this particular
bill uh section nine and section ten
and with section with respect to section
ten to the public water access advisory
board
uh their suggestions are good and we
certainly support those
number nine the only problem that we
have is the removal of the words
all of whom shall be residents of the
seacoast region
and we successfully communicated to the
committee the need for this advisory
board but apparently didn't successfully
communicate just how closely tied
that particular advisory board is to the
commercial fishing
industry in the state of new hampshire
which really is
centered on the seacoast i think the
concern that the advisory board
expressed when they got back to us was
they didn't want a situation
that could potentially happen where no
members of their advisory commission
were from seacoast towns or connected to
the commercial fishing industry
so that's why we've raised this point
in this is a very active board in fact
they met as recently as last evening
uh they deal with issues that really
aren't dealt with elsewhere in the state
such as working with the national marine
fisheries
uh council working with the atlantic
state marine fisheries commission
dealing with the department of commerce
and noaa
on fishing and fishing enforcement these
are
issues that really are located in this
particular industry and located and
centered in the seacoast region of the
state
so we really would appreciate it if
there were no change to this particular
commission and with that in mind to be
happy to take any questions from the
committee
uh thank you um are there any i see one
hand representative lay
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking the the question so
um mr sanderson uh how do you define or
what is the definition of seacoast
region
uh we actually have it in part of our
fish and game statutes
it's in rsa 206 2-8 and it it
deals with the appointment of a special
commissioner to the fish and game
commission
from the hounds and it involves 17 towns
that are in the city i could read them
for you no that's okay
that's okay as long as you have a
definition that's that's what i was
concerned follow-up mr chair
absolutely go ahead so the work of this
uh particular commission concerns uh
obviously the commercial marine
fisheries business
um is it possible that somebody could be
deeply engaged in that business
uh but live outside those 17 towns
uh they may well live outside of those
towns but they certainly work in those
towns
that that's where the industry really is
centered we don't have any commercial
fishing processors in the marine area
that are outside of this particular
region
my concern is that the the language
being deleted states
quite explicitly they must be residents
of that region
so if they live outside that region but
are engaged in business
in that region as you just stated they
would be barred from membership on this
commission correct
that is correct follow up
if the committee were to consider it an
improvement that they in being so
involved in the commercial fishing
industry regardless of where they reside
that would meet that concern
that so would you object to a change
like that
would uh i don't think that they would
because that certainly is what they're
really trying to get at here is having
people who are actively
fishing industry uh be the ones helping
and advising our marine division
so so there could be a possibility where
rather than defining it in terms of
place of residence it could be defined
in terms of uh engagement with
a particular uh business correct
thank you representative roulard thank
you
you know representative lay and i are on
the same page on this
um i i was concerned about uh somebody
that had a specific expertise and
perhaps had been involved
with this particular fish and game
group and perhaps moved outside
of that area and maybe somebody that
would
be able to provide expertise because
maybe they were part
of this particular board in the past
and the way that this is worded all of
whom
shall be and my thought was perhaps the
majority
of them be from that group but not
exclude people that you may
feel or that this group may feel would
be an absolute
asset so although i i understand that
residents could be changed
to folks engaged it also could be
individuals that had previously been on
the board and the way that this
is it's limiting the whole enchilada
and i i think we probably um would not
want to have
all of whom but i wondered if that would
be a problem
at all mr sanderson i think that your
suggestions are good ones
and that what we're trying to do is
reflect the necessary expertise on the
board
any sort of a change along that line
would be a beneficial change
terrific thank you any further questions
seeing none seeing no hands raised um
thank you mr sanderson um i have one
would there be a any uh concern it
it sounded to me when um when the prime
sponsor of the bill
was speaking that there may have been a
a question about the ability to
fill the committee that there was
difficulty in getting
um enough people to fill it is that
a concern or no that really has not been
a concern
okay um thank you very much for taking
the time um
appreciate your testimony and thank you
and members of the committee
uh seeing no other
people who have signed up to speak on
this
um are there any i will ask if there are
any members of the
public um with their hands raised uh
representative green
can you see anyone i do not
no hands as of yet
um
are there people on telephone that need
to instructions on how to raise their
hand
or are is everyone on doom
everyone's on on doom with uh yeah no
telephone
uh participants or attendees all right
um i think with that i'm comfortable
then with
closing the hearing on house bill 186.
[Music]
the time being 9 39
um we've passed the time in the calendar
that
had listed the executive session um i'm
happy to
now open the executive session
and immediately recess the
uh executive session to a date certain
which we believe will be march 29th
um hoping for well we have the request
in for march 29th
at 10 o'clock um
my suggestion is that you keep an eye on
the calendar
um in the house
because we really don't know
there seems to be in the list i saw a
number of
committees all meeting that week so
where we meet what time we meet um but
we would be
as a committee um dealing with all of
the remaining bills we have including
this one
186 um on that
on that day um and beyond that
um i have no further business up i see a
hand by
representative lay or just a quick
question and it really just goes back to
hb 186 was the insurance department rep
actually suggest he was suggesting
another technical amendment to this
um yes representative lay he
had sent in okay
so i haven't seen yeah okay he had sent
in
i think uh representative roulard saw
that did you not
um i'm trying to think of i don't know
if he just sent it to me
or whether he sent it to the entire
committee i know
um pam saw it um cam smarling but um
there was it they were just it was the
technical corrections of
where that um
was referenced throughout the statute so
that's that was all that was in there
but we could certainly i'll certainly
make sure the
entire committee gets it if they haven't
already been sent it
okay thank you um anything else from
anyone else that uh
we need to discuss
that's good things are smooth all right
so um the next thing uh you'll see i
guess
is the calendar uh listing when our
executive session
and for some of the newer folks
because the deadline has been moved out
that gave us the ability to move this
this executive session out and hopefully
fit into
everybody's work schedules a little bit
better yeah
i see them um
and uh and i think uh that's it for
today
so enjoy the rest of your day and we'll
see you
probably the 29th great thank you
bye